then there's this whole world of
biotechnology
our genetic understanding is already
leading to big strides in human health
the mrna breakthrough that just came
through in the pandemic is just a taste
of things to come
i think we're finally ready to see
biotechnology's full
impact arguably biotech is where
infotech was in the 1990s now the
fundamental drivers of information
technologies
that drove the lost long boom have to do
with exponential drops in
costs allowing exponential rise in scale
it turns out that the cost curve in
genome sequencing
is beating moore's law at this point in
it costs two billion dollars to
crack one human genome by 2010
that cost had dropped to two million per
one human
genome today it's less than a thousand
bucks there's some limit but
ultimately you can imagine over the
course of the next decade it's gonna be
super cheap if not
close to free so i think we're
underestimating how we could reinvent
healthcare
now we're still in the very early days
of crispr techniques but we're on the
road to widespread
genetic engineering and we are already
moving
beyond human health problems into
synthetic biology now this is not just
genetic engineering but wider biological
engineering
we now are understanding how cells work
as well
as how the genome works and we're able
to apply that now not
basically to all living things so for
example we're already seeing how it's
impacting
food and ultimately starting to grip
into cell-based meat
we could be seeing close to 40 to 50
percent
of the meat we eat could actually be
uh cell-based meat over the course of
this period we're talking about here
and we could see truly sustainable
materials to replace let's say
the scourge of plastics that's mounting
all over
all these things in the biotech field
could help our ongoing challenge of
dealing with climate change i think we
could see a complete inversion of how we
produce
things a fundamental shift to actually
grow things
with very little waste from the bottom
up